Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two. David P
voicemails pouring in about the Will Smith slap
of Chris Rock at the Oscars on Sunday. People
wanting to talk about race, people wanting to
talk about domestic violence, people wanting to
talk about defending one's honor here is someone
who's just baffled by some of the response we've
seen to the incident. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 7: I, David, I'm truly baffled by the
responses I'm seeing to the Will Smith slap.
I'm watching a video by Jocko Elway right now,
who I actually think is the perfect example
for everything that is wrong in America right
now. I guess he wants every man, woman and
child in America to be a navy seal platoon
and to live their lives like they were overseas
and tasked with killing an innocent
civilian family or something like that.
So that's a good for him. There's just a way of
letting off steam talk smack. You get smacked.
So. We're all about smacking people nowadays.
Speaker 1: It really is we are now, I think
it's important for context to show that we now
have I mean, listen, we can we can get polling
very quickly on any topic in the United States.
Most people are taking the side of Chris Rock in
the sense that they're saying, Listen, he told
the joke, and there's no justification for the
physical violence. But even some people on
Twitter of tweeted to me and they've said,
Listen, Jada Pinkett Smith has taken a lot of crap
over the years. Why are you justifying violence?
Because that's really what it's about. And at the
end of the day, these are millionaires sitting in
the front row at the Oscars, where, you know,
there's some degree of like a kind of roasted
scenario there. And alopecia is not what we would
call a disability. It is a medical condition. And
it's not even really clear what Chris Rock knows
about it. And you can talk whatever you want. But
we're we're talking about words here and
then we're talking about an adult walking
on stage and slapping Chris Rock. And it
is weird. It is baffling, to some degree,
how quickly some are jumping to defend acts of
physical violence. It's disturbing. We've got a
great bonus show for you today. Russia is claiming
that they're scaling down military action in Kiev,
but I think we're right to be skeptical
of it. We'll talk about what we know.
Joe Biden has also made lynching
a hate crime in the United States,
and some House Republicans are angry that
Madison Cawthorn is telling stories about a coke
laden orgies in Washington, DC. We will talk
about all of those stories on the bonus show.
Sign up at Join Packman.
Unidentified: Com to get instant access.